Venezuela is dumping the dollar when it
comes to official exchange transactions
and will now use the Euro or other
convertible currencies instead the move
is retaliation for severe American
financial sanctions imposed on the
country's officials including the
president though Caracas is not alone in
moving away from Dadar dependence as
Daniel Bushell reports Norma's the land
of the world's top oil reserves
announces no more buying or selling in
greenbacks you know let us be free we
will not be anyone's colony again
the latest in an hour apparently
non-stop barrage of hits to the pinata
of the dollar system the impregnable
tender since world war ii and guess
whose currency Caracas is ousted it for
after Trump threatened anyone dealing
with Iran
Brussels drops a bombshell on its old US
chum in Iran trade you simply ditching
the dollar EU Member State will set up a
legal entity to facilitate legitimate
financial transactions with Iran and
this will allow European companies to
continue to trade with Iran in
accordance with European Union law and
could be open to other partners in the
world
Russia's back in Brussels Vladimir Putin
is already talking dollar trade with
major allies adding Washington's just
shot itself in the foot actually many
guns keep our American partners are
making a colossal strategic mistake
undermining the credibility of the
dollar is a universal and essentially
the only reserve currency and the mining
trust in it they're cutting the branch
they're sitting on this is a typical
mistake of any Empire when people think
that nothing will happen they believe
that everything is so powerful so strong
so stable that there will be no negative
consequences you know they will come
sooner or later
but the hardest wallop of all maybe from
America's biggest rival China Beijing's
shop window now plans an ample dollar
free range from oil trade in petrol you
on the online crypto you on the New Silk
Road
Colossus and Beijing's own Swift world
banking network even US media admit
Washington's now waging economic war on
1/10 of the world and one in four people
on this planet now live on the
government's committed to drown dollar
dominance mainstream economists
pooh-pooh any future without a glorious
greenback ensuring any smash will only
be more shocking
you